this video is an ad for seriously I
don't know the ever just feel like you
wake up and you do the same thing over
and over again like nothing changes are
you saying right now I just need to find
myself
[Music]
what you use
it's got hard games you're feeling
something and I need to help I just feel
like a new person you look like a new
person
I went on a journey and I found this new
game that came out today if anyone were
to click the link in the description
below and download the game they'd be an
amazing person best fiends forever
[Music]
for in like a seriously yeah
we hope you enjoyed this video there are
other trailers made by your other
favorite youtubers available in the
description below and download best
fiends forever from furry today tell us
which trailer is your favorite by voting
through the like button
you